[Música]
é boa tarde para quem é da tarde ea
bênção pra quem é de bênção é eu sou uma
baiana de joão pessoa nasce lá por acaso
porque eu sou do tempo da cegonha e a
cegonha disse que deveria deveria ficar
ali porque a lei é pra missa e quando eu
crescer se eu procurasse um lugar bom
para viver e hoje colhi joão pessoa e
aqui estou
é eu sou filha de dona jacira com o seu
antônio uma família que morava nos
alagados
não sei se vocês sabe alegados são casas
em cima da água ea gente caminhava sobre
as pontes e foi lá que eu aprendi a
andar e estudei na minha mãe tinha essa
preocupação e que pobre tem que sonhar
o pobre tem que estudar e estudei me
formei
mas um dia eu sou a primeira a primeira
de oito filhos
um dia minha mãe no momento de gás tura
que toda mãe que se preza tem disse pra
mim de que eu gostava de ler demais e
que pobre não pode sonhar pobre tem
necessidades
ela estava certa só que eu impacto
porque ela dizia que tinha que estudar
pra ser uma pessoa da vida e ao mesmo
tempo eu não podia ler meus livros fui
procurar meu pai e ele me aconselhou que
eu deveria mas antes deveria pensar
melhor sobre a fala da minha mãe eu me
sentei e escrever
fiz um plano de vida que não sabia na
época era pelo desabafo porque sou do
tempo em que filho não reclama com a mãe
nem com o pai escuta se curva encerrou o
assunto
eu escrevi e coloquei essa informação e
se inscrito dentro desse livro que eu
estava lendo e fui procurar sair da
minha solução
meu pai me ajudou e eu fui
conseguir resolver o problema da minha
mãe que era um problema financeiro e
continuei minha vida estudei estudei e
estudei e cortei o cabelo meu pai era
barbeiro na época e eu aprendi a arte de
cortar cabelo e foi com esse dinheiro
que eu me mantive me mantive sonho da
minha mãe e dos meus irmãos
um dia eu recebi um papel na escola onde
estudava ensinava e nesse papel tinha
muito dinheiro
é o tradicional quanto ao cheque e eu me
sentei me sentei no campo grande que é
um lugar que eu gostava muito de
refletir e decidir que com aquele
dinheiro eu ia transformar a minha vida
foi à rodoviária
encontrei um moço lá sentado é um
despachante e perguntei pra ele qual é o
lugar mais calmo do nordeste ele disse
que era joão pessoa
aqui era tão calmo que só tinha dois
ônibus e saía brasil e diga pra lá que
eu vou
comprei minha passagem e fui pra casa
pra dar essa notícia a minha mãe que me
para meu pai era mais fácil mas eu fui
criada pela minha avó foi minha avó que
me deu os grandes ensinamentos da minha
vida quando eu me achava como um momento
desse que minha mãe dizer bem lendo pelo
amor de deus minha avó dizia tenha calma
você
o ser humano não escolhe onde nasci
isso é coisa de deus não se discute mas
o ser humano escolhe onde vai morrer
isso é coisa do homem e da mulher e é
com essa frase eu ganhei a minha vida
ig a vida de muitas pessoas
vim para joão pessoa é cuidar da
catavento fui dona da copa pitada de um
dia eu lendo abrindo meu
livros e encontrei a frase enquanto eu
penso que tinha escrito aos 13 anos
pobre pode sonhar sim e com esse papel
na mão
relembrei minha mãe helen minha volta
inteira à minha frente
ela sempre conduziu com palavras
formosas uma grande sábia e eu peguei
esse papel disse agora é a hora de e em
busca do meu sonho porque eu sei lidar
com criança esse é o meu fazer melhor e
maior é onde eu me realizo e aí o que eu
tinha eu tinha algumas com os meus bens
que eu juntei que eu não sou uma pessoa
gasta à beira de uma pessoa parada então
quem é parado não gasta não é só gasta
quem anda quem não anda guarda e peguei
esse é esse papel e reescrevia minha
vida
consultei algumas amigas mais próximas e
decidi que eu venderia tudo que juntei
até ali porque ele não me pertencia
aquilo foi resultado de um desafio um
bom desafio mais um desafio
ia construir um lugar aonde crianças
daquele da minha faixa etária da minha
da minha parte econômica pudesse sonhar
e pudesse também tem necessidades porque
o sonho quando está aliançado com a
necessidade é uma das coisas mais belas
que existe na vida porque uma grande
árvore derruba suas folhas aos seus pés
e às vezes dentro levo é da outra né ele
se transforma no seu nutriente e assim o
fiz de tudo consultei as minhas amigas
mais sérias
mas é uma decisão tomada
procurei esse lugar que se chama gramame
eu não conhecia muitos de vocês não
conhece e lá encontrei um espaço onde
construir um espaço bonito que sonhar é
bom foi a eu sou e muitas vezes naqueles
colchões de cheia de palha não é mas é
bom sonhar aquele cachorro quente deixa
o al coisa boa e pulso com essas pessoas
essas minhas amigas construir nesse
espaço onde hoje habita 120 crianças não
se tenham tem nos critérios para entrar
na verdade todo o processo da escola foi
sendo construída a partir delas
quem chegou primeiro que a menina é bom
por isso - chegou a espiar e pergunta o
que é isso pra que isso porque aquilo
menino não tem vergonha que tem vergonha
somos nós adultos que pensamos mas não
falamos e pensamos e não falamos e
ficamos com as nossas cabeças chez e o
corpo cheio de de coisas não boas né
mas que não tem isso e foi entrando as
primeiras as segundas terceiras nas
quartas e com elas juntas construímos a
escola viva olho do tempo que é o que a
gente faz desde
ele tem pra trás até hoje fazemos
algumas coisas apenas aperfeiçoamos a
cada ano
acho que aperfeiçoa mas o objetivo deste
espaço
nada mais é do que fazer as pessoas
sonharem
às vezes as pessoas me perguntam 'você
tá tirando o menino das drogas não eu
não posso eu não tenho essa competência
de tirar ninguém das drogas
eu tenho competência de mostrar pra eles
que ele é um ser humano bonito poderoso
e que ele sim pode sair se ele quiser
a história da humanidade aí pra provar
que ninguém tira ninguém de nada a
transformação como diria minha avó
sempre ela está aqui dentro de mim que
minha avó me dizia nos meus momentos de
desespero quando eu tinha oito crianças
vai dar conta
ela dizia transformação tá dentro de ti
chora é bom é bom mas não serve o que
serve sorri diante da diversidade
precisamos sorrir seu sorriso que não
nos permite dar um passo à frente às
lágrimas em pacca porque elas turbo
nossos olhos e assim continuam com tirei
a minha caminhada durante selar a minha
vida inteira e temos hoje esse espaço do
sonhar
do sonhar através da música do sonhar
através da percussão do sonhar
através da dança do sonhar através de um
bom livro do sonhar fazenda usando
aquelas máquinas da tecnologias e assim
se dá o aprendizado perdão o aprendizado
da vida como professora só eu me formei
em letras eu fiz meu mestrado que era a
minha carta de alforria eu tinha que
dizer à minha mãe e minha filha você e
eu sou do tempo que a mulher sai da
indicada para casar ou pra estudar eles
a minha mãe que ia estudar
estudei ter mestrado aqui em joão pessoa
e mandei pra minha mãe o meu o meu
certificado para que ela se acalmasse
não é porque uma mãe gosta de chorar
muito quando o filho vai para ali ou vai
pra cá né mãe pensa esse dom maravilhoso
mesmo tendo oito filho faz uma falta
danada né
ao longo da minha caminhada eu aprendi a
importância do abraço a importância de
estar junto um outro a importância de
poder não precisa e não precisa saber o
nome dessa moça ela é tão humana quanto
eu e só você chegar perto dela para
conversar
a gente provou o dia todinho sempre
estar saber que eu me chamo dossiê que
ela se chama sniper nome livro não
precisa o importante é o calor humano
que nós estamos perdendo porque essa
máquina hoje que nós usamos com todos os
dias todas as horas
então estamos separando lá na escola os
meninos já sabe que entram na escola ea
máquina fica na caixinha é um lugar de
máquina a manhã toda a tarde inteira é
para que nós nos juntamos para brincar
que lugar de criança é brincando e é
brincando que a gente aprende brincando
que a gente aprende a ser a trabalhar
nossas gastura as nossas mágoas nossas
vidas é brincando
não adianta falar sério com criança que
criança não escuta criança escuta a
brincadeira
e isso ao longo da minha vida eu aprendi
foi assim que o eduquei meus irmãos
brincando tem uma diversidade muito
difícil vamos brincar com ela porque
viver é brincar
segundo a minha avó não tem comida
vamos brincar porque a comida parece e
ela parece parece brincadeira mas ela
parece é uma questão só de como a gente
só do nosso coração e principalmente a
nossa mente porque ela que reside todas
as nossas gastura por isso que a gente
não usa o nosso cérebro que se usássemos
nossos cérebros
a bíblia nossa vida seria melhor porque
a nossa mente é traiçoeira como dizia
minha vó minha vó dizer pensa com a
cabeça durante muito tempo e não entende
o que é pensar com a cabeça e ela me
disse exatamente ela trai
então se você escuta algo de alguém
pensa primeiro o que é que você está
fazendo com a sua vida para que o outro
deu um beliscão ou porque você está ali
parado naquele lugar recebeu um beliscão
então antes de você revidar um beliscão
pensa pensa pensa que ela estava certa
ao longo da minha vida as pessoas minhas
amigas dizem que eu tenho um sangue frio
mas não tem um sangue frio
eu tenho sangue quente eu só penso eu só
uso essa marca que tem aqui dentro da
cabeça e os braços para abraçar e
abraçar o mundo sim porque o mundo é uma
pessoa
o mundo é uma pessoa hoje eu tô cheio
imundos
mas o mundo é só uma pessoa a cada
criança que chega perto de mim é o mundo
e esse mundo é sobre esse mundo ea gente
precisa se curvar que a gente se curva
pouco a gente dá muita muita sorte as
crianças muitas ordens ea gente precisa
é conversar com as nossas crianças para
que desperte dentro de nós
a criança que existe dentro da gente
[Música]
beber e andar com a cabeça na terra e os
pés no céu
hum
[Música]
mas a gata nessa terra é mãe de deus
colocando fim à esperança
foi também o papel levanta é cada um é
com a apuração até aqui esperando no
acesso a dizer pequena assim
i am
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ae